I'm the deputy of the state of Illinois at Black Panther Party 3 in Hampton.
And we are going to have to fight, we're going to have to struggle.
We're going to have to struggle relentlessly to bring about some peace.
Because the people that we're acting for peace, they're a bunch of megalomaniac warm-mongers.
And they don't even understand what these means.
And we've got to fight them, we've got to struggle with them to make them understand what these means.
And we don't care what everybody says.
We don't think it's paid five or five minutes because we think it's paid five or five minutes.
We're going to fight racism, not racism, but we're going to fight this out there.
We say we're not going to fight capitalism, we're black capitalism, but we're going to fight socialism.
Why do I have a lot of risk because of harassment?
Why is there harassment?
Because the people that harass me have set up a problem that made me disagree with them violently.
And they set up this problem in order to exploit me and other people like me.
And why do they want to get rid of me because I'm saying something that might wake up some other exploited people and some other oppressed people.
And if all these people ever get together, then these people today exploit.
Unless we'll be running into the lake. That's why they want to get rid of us.